probablemente han visto plantas ya sea
en su casa o cuando salen a caminar y
han visto que algunas partes de las
plantas se tuercen y giran en todas las
direcciones y si observamos de cerca
podremos ver que la mayoría de las veces
parece que la planta se tuerce o gira
hacia la luz así que lo que haremos en
este vídeo es estudiar este fenómeno
vamos a ver en general cuando hablamos
de un organismo que va creciendo y
cambiando de dirección debido a
estímulos externos a eso se le conoce
como tropismo
tropismo y en el caso en el que cambian
de dirección debido a que el estímulo
externo es luz a eso le llamamos foto
tropismo foto tropismo y foto tropismo
es un término general para cualquier
tipo de organismo que cambia de
dirección o que se mueve en cierta
dirección a causa de la luz y se puede
mover ya sea hacia la luz o lejos de la
luz ahora la mayoría de las plantas que
observamos por ejemplo si vamos a un
bosque veremos que hay una abertura por
la que entra la luz y generalmente
podemos encontrar árboles y plantas que
se encuentran creciendo hacia esa luz
crecen en dirección hacia la luz
entonces si se mueven hacia la luz a
esto se le conoce como foto tropismo
positivo y si por alguna razón hay algún
tipo de planta que se mueve lejos de la
luz a eso se le llama foto tropismo
negativo que es menos común sobre todo
por el tallo de una planta
pero hablaremos más sobre eso en otros
vídeos entonces generalmente veremos un
foto tropismo positivo como este y la
pregunta es como hace eso la planta qué
es lo que provoca que se mueva en
dirección hacia la luz en el caso de
foto tropismo positivo bueno aquí el
personaje principal es una molécula
llamada auxina aux-in y la ocs china es
una fitohormona citó hormona significa
que es una molécula involucrada con el
crecimiento de la planta entonces qué
pasa vamos a acercarnos a esta planta y
solo para ser claros sabemos cómo actúa
la auxina pero todos los mecanismos por
los que cambia la distribución de la
auxina o por los que es activada o
desactivada todavía no se han explicado
por completo y todavía es una área
activa de investigación pero lo que sí
sabemos es que
supongamos que la luz viene en esta
dirección y por varias razones aumenta
la concentración de oxígeno activa en el
lado de la planta que está lejos de la
luz entonces en este caso si la luz
viene del lado izquierdo tenemos mas
auxina del lado derecho de la que hay de
lado izquierdo y la ocs inah de la
derecha provoca que las células del lado
derecho del tallo se estiren entonces si
nos acercamos más vamos a acercarnos más
a esta parte de la planta si nos
acercamos más supongamos que estas son
las células del lado izquierdo y estas
son las otras células entonces si
tenemos más auxina si tenemos más de esa
fitohormona del lado derecho que del
lado izquierdo lo que sabemos que ocurre
es que esa fitohormona provoca que estas
paredes celulares en las que hay mas
auxina se estiren o mejor dicho sea
entonces lo que ocurre es que voy a
dibujarlo las células del lado derecho
se van a estirar se van a estirar o
alargar porque hay más presencia de oxy
na de este lado que del lado derecho y
como aquí tenemos una concentración más
alta de auxina activa estas células se
estiren y entonces si el lado derecho es
más largo que el lado izquierdo que pasa
claro la planta se curva hacia la
izquierda entonces la planta se curva
porque ahora el lado derecho es más
largo que el lado izquierdo entonces
esto es lo que sabemos sobre la auxina
es una fitohormona que donde sea que se
encuentre activa en altas
concentraciones las células se van a
estirar provocando que la planta se
curve y bueno lo que aún se está
investigando es que es lo que provoca
que aumente la concentración de auc zinc
en este caso del lado derecho y cuáles
son exactamente
todos los mecanismos por los que actúa
la oxida lo que sabemos es que crea un
ambiente más ácido que ayuda a romper
las paredes celulares pero cómo es que
se logra una concentración alta del lado
derecho bueno se han estudiado muchas
plantas y se ha descubierto que la luz
azul es la que provoca la sensibilidad
aquí dibujé la luz de amarillo pero en
realidad la luz azul es la que causa la
sensibilidad aunque no siempre es la luz
azul podría ser luz roja o cualquier
otra frecuencia de la luz y las teorías
dicen que cuando tenemos luz de un lado
de la planta una posible explicación es
que eso provoca que la auxina migra
hacia el lado en el que hay menos luz
pero hay otras teorías de que más bien
la luz desactiva la auxina del lado
izquierdo o de que tal vez se produce
menos auxina de la que se produce del
lado derecho todas esas son posibles
explicaciones y eso es lo más
interesante sobre la ciencia siempre hay
más por descubrir y por
pero por ahora lo que sí sabemos es que
este tipo de foto tropismo que
generalmente vemos en el bosque o
incluso en una planta de la casa si la
ponemos junto a una ventana porque
generalmente crece hacia la ventana este
foto tropismo es provocado por la auxina
y la distribución de auxina cambia en
respuesta a la luz pues para el foto
tropismo positivo la distribución de
auxina incrementa del lado contrario a
la luz ahora en esta fotografía parece
que hay foto tropismo pero en realidad
esta es una planta mutante que carece de
auxina por eso crece en todas
direcciones pero es interesante verla